the movie is set in the year 2070. many
renowned scientists of the world are
distressed because of the risk of a
worldwide drought due to water scarcity
to prepare for such a situation
beforehand a group of researchers are
sent to the ball hay research station on
the moon their first experiment is
performed on a fish inside a tank they
expose it to a few drops of mysterious
liquid similar to water initially it
causes the fish to suffocate but then
the molecules multiply forming more
water and eventually filling up the tank
in short the fish managed to create a
survivable environment on its own thanks
to the mysterious liquid although the
first experiment was a success something
mysterious causes the station to close
soon after and the base is forgotten
five years later in 2075 the forecast
comes true and the world is hit with a
critical worldwide water shortage it has
resulted in an all-time infant mortality
rate due to various infections and
diseases caused by the consumption of
contaminated water government and
private organizations in south korea are
vigorously investing in mega-vertical
farms in hopes of reducing water usage
moreover the government has divided the
public into separate groups and each
group gets different quality and
quantities of water depending on the
group's importance to human survival
expectedly the scheme isn't popular with
most of the general public as they are
now deprived of clean water then we are
introduced to a korean space agency
named saa the agency led by director
choi is planning to send a crew to the
ball hey lunar research station it is
the same abandoned research facility on
the moon where the fish experiment was
conducted it hides many government
secrets some of which might even solve
the water problems on earth the crew
consists of nine members all led by
captain han a soldier for the space
agency the mission is especially
dangerous because in the last research
117 crew members died in the base they
are told that the deaths were caused due
to a radiation leak but dr song doesn't
want to believe it for the mission joy
has roped in dr song an astrobiologist
she initially turned down the mission
but later changed her mind for the sake
of finding out the truth about her late
sister who also lost her life in the
ball hey accident five years ago as a
reward dr song is given a lifetime gold
membership which gives her unlimited
access to safe and clean drinking water
director choi briefs the crew about the
mission it turns out that they have to
retrieve at least one capsule of a
research sample from the station on the
moon however the information on what the
samples consist of is supposedly lost
and unknown all they know is that the
samples must be kept at a regulated low
temperature range dr song suspects that
the saa is purposely withholding
information about the parcel's content
but still decides to go on the mission
on the day of the takeoff the main pilot
is replaced by a pilot named jisoo the
crew isn't happy with the last minute
change but captain han orders everyone
to stick it out the spacecraft takes off
and safely enters the earth and later
the moon's orbit however during the
landing it malfunctions and they crash
on the moon's surface 7.6 kilometers
northwest of their destination the
mission spacecraft falls off a cliff and
the surviving crew is forced to travel
to the station by foot a former
researcher at the ball hay station named
huang has sustained serious injury
halfway through the journey he stops and
is unable to continue since he has been
to the station before for research he
seems to know something that the others
don't he tries to convey a message to
the crew but ends up passing away
dealing a serious blow to the crew's
morale nevertheless they continue their
journey and almost run out of oxygen
when they reach their destination at
ball hey station they desperately fill
up the tanks and manage to survive the
series then flashes back to the past and
dr song is seen trying to find out the
truth about her sister's death she opens
an encrypted file from her sister's
workstation trying to find out what she
was working on at the lunar station she
eventually cracks the code and a message
pops up on the screen that reads find
luna back to the present the crew comes
across an old corpse that has physical
signs similar to that of drowning they
are confused because there couldn't
possibly be enough water on the moon for
a person to drown and die the crew is
not able to identify the dead body from
their database and are puzzled to see an
automatic weapon in the corpse's
possession suggesting that he was a
mercenary moreover all the systems of
the station are functional and the
station lacks the dangerous radiation
that had allegedly wiped out the staff
five years prior dr song's belief that
saa is keeping them in the dark becomes
stronger and she suggests performing an
autopsy of the corpse but the captain
orders everyone to stick to the plan and
look for the command center instead they
eventually locate the center and bring
the massive facility back to life
however the communication system is down
and the crew isn't able to contact
mission control the radiation levels in
the control room seem normal unlike what
the mission control had told them dr
song boldly takes off her life support
to prove that they are not surrounded by
high levels of radiation and then
everyone follows her lead bold strategy
cotton let's see if it pays off for them
she again suggests performing a full
inspection of the station but han
reminds her that it's not their job to
investigate the cause of the ball high
accident they are here to retrieve the
samples which is their first and only
priority there are three storages in the
facility where the sample could possibly
be found so the crew splits up into
teams and searches the station for
viable samples a crew member named dr
hong a soldier e2 and the captain head
for storage one taisuk sun su-chan and
e-1 are sent to storage 2. meanwhile
chief gong dr song and jisoo go to
storage three dr song tells the crew
that as soon as they locate the capsule
they must check the thermoregulator to
make sure that it's at an extremely low
temperature on the way to storage three
gc reveals that captain han returned
back from retirement on this mission for
a special purpose he wants to get his
sick daughter access to a higher class
of water it turns out that after the
great drought one in every 10 children
passes away meanwhile team 1 comes
across a jammed gate when they force
open the door they come across a number
of corpses frightening the team a quick
assessment of the situation shows that
the victims were desperately trying to
escape and the area was shut down in an
emergency right after the accident the
situation is contrary to the government
report which stated that the victims
died way before the shutdown dr song
observes the bodies remotely from her
wrist computer and comments on their
characteristics of drowned bodies she
insists on checking the infirmary to
access their medical records and han
rudely turns her down telling her to
take her mind off of her personal
curiosity the first and second group
eventually reach their respective
destinations but the visible capsules
are empty or missing and the storage
units look as if someone already raided
the place for the samples in the
meantime team 3 detects a foreign
presence moving around the station when
the head of security gong goes around to
inspect jisoo tells dr song that he
knows about her late sister and
empathizes with her he also reveals that
if she wishes to check the infirmary to
get to the bottom of the truth he would
cover for her after a brief pause dr
song decides to utilize the opportunity
somewhere else crew member sue chan of
team 2 sees a corpse with a capsule in
his hands he touches the corpse which
upon contact releases minuscule particle
droplets that enter su-chan's eyes after
dr song leaves for the infirmary jisu
enters storage 3 on his own and looks
around for samples in the process he
drops his flashlight when he tries to
fetch it some invisible force seemingly
pulls it away frightening the hell out
of him he collects himself and brushes
it aside as a hallucination back to team
2 after failing to locate a viable
capsule they head back to the command
center han on the other hand monitors dr
song's movements from his watch and
orders her to rejoin jisoo immediately
inside storage three gc notices a viable
capsule near the flashlight and manages
to retrieve it the capsule appears to be
filled with water when dr song returns
to storage 3 she notices some unknown
entity attacking jisoo and lifting him
up in the air by his neck before
dropping him to his death dr song also
notices the entity taking the capsule
away before disappearing soon others
arrive and learn about the incident as
expected they find it hard to believe dr
song's account but a quick analysis of
jisu's body reveals a fractured skull
ankle and arm which couldn't have
possibly resulted from a fall han orders
everyone to return to the command center
before going through dr song's body
camera with gong it turns out the
intruder escaped through the ventilation
system since the intruder realized the
value of the sample and hence took it
away song theorizes that the intruder is
a human back at the command center team
member tai sook tries to establish
contact with mission control and after
failing to succeed he hypothesizes that
there might be a problem with the radio
tower outside suddenly su chan starts
shaking violently and expels unnatural
amounts of water dr hong orders everyone
to step back and put on their hazmat
suits han gong and song also learn about
the situation and rush back to the
command center dr hong tries her best to
save su-chan but he eventually dies from
drowning symptoms much like the corpses
littering the station dr hong tells han
that they must quarantine su-chan's body
until they determine the exact cause of
death she proposes moving him to the
main lab infirmary and performing an
autopsy right away chief gong is shaken
by his brother's death and han attempts
to comfort him han also finally gives
song permission to go through the
medical records of the ball hey crew who
lost their lives in the accident the
crew also learns that the entity that
killed jisoo can access areas that are
not in the station's blueprints han
decides to search the ventilation shaft
with gong and e2 while team members tai
sook and sun are ordered to establish
contact with mission control sun is
severely demoralized by the recent
events and sook tries to cheer him up
while trying to establish communication
with mission control dr hong performs an
autopsy of su chan's body while song and
another soldier named e1 unsuccessfully
try to access the encrypted medical
records of the crew who lost their lives
in the accident five years ago song
decides to secure tissue samples from
other bodies and trace them back to when
su chan's symptoms broke out meanwhile
han gong and e2 enter the ventilation
system to look for the entity and come
across drawings seemingly made by it
soon they notice a biosignal approaching
them from the front and wait to come
face to face with the entity however it
passes them by as song collects tissue
samples from the dead bodies e1 wonders
if he also got infected since he came in
contact with sue chan suddenly dr hong
calls song back to the infirmary and the
latter asks e1 to take care of the
samples for her before heading back on
her way she suddenly stops before the
data storage chamber of the station
after a brief pause she rejoins e1 to
collect more samples afterward they
return back to the infirmary and dr hong
reveals that su-chan drowned to death
and the water rose up from the inside
song goes through the samples collected
from other bodies but fails to locate
anything unusual han and the others
continue to follow the entity's bio
signal which leads them to a gate that
requires level 1 access left with no
choice han and his team return to the
command center there taisu informs him
that there's a problem with the digital
unit connected to the communications
tower and someone needs to go outside to
switch the equipment while another edits
the protocol inside and reboots the
system without blinking han volunteers
to do the job back at the infirmary dr
hong shows song su-chan's blood sample
which contains an unknown substance soon
han arrives and informs them about the
latest development before he leaves song
privately talks to him and expresses
amazement at the intruder not attacking
her even when she got really close to it
maybe the intruder is a simp moreover
since it moves by using shafts and it
always manages to escape because it's a
step ahead it seems like the entity is
familiar with the internal structure of
the facility song strongly believes that
the entity could be a human survivor
from five years ago even though han
finds it hard to believe song tells him
that if the government could be wrong
about the radiation levels it could very
well be mistaken about survivors too han
retorts that if it really was a survivor
it wouldn't have stolen the sample and
attacked them as han heads out to repair
the communication system the movie
flashes back to the past han is seen
walking to the national medical center
his daughter is admitted to the hospital
and the doctor tells him that he needs a
higher water classification to stop her
condition from worsening if her
condition worsens she could lose her
legs forever back in the present song
and tong analyze the water in su-chan's
blood it has the solubility and surface
tension of water but different mass and
density also it doesn't contain any
microorganisms and hence is similar to
distilled water meanwhile han climbs
down the station using a safety harness
to fix the communication system however
out of nowhere the defunct platform
elevator below him becomes operational
and shoots above knocking the safety
harness out han narrowly saves his life
and holds onto a wall until the crew
above drops another rope unfortunately
the elevator again free-falls from the
top and the crew is forced to drop the
rope han manages to anchor his rope on
the wall before jumping out of the
elevator's way in the process he damages
his life support system he rapidly loses
his oxygen but insists on returning only
after fixing the communication system he
eventually brings the system back up but
before he can return he collapses to the
ground back at the infirmary song points
out that the water in su-chan's body
stopped increasing in quantity after his
death since it multiplies rapidly once
the host is infected and stops its
activity when the host dies water could
be a virus meanwhile when han opens his
eyes he finds himself inside the station
it turns out gong and e2 brought him
back after he lost consciousness due to
lack of oxygen they returned to the
command center and to their dismay they
learned that there's no exchange of
signals from mission control despite the
system not showing any malfunction
suddenly the computer detects an unknown
signal coming in from outside and being
sent to the storage 3 area han and the
others immediately rush there and
investigate jisu's body upon searching
his corpse they discover a mobile device
with which he had been maintaining
periodic contact with an outside
organization it turns out that he was
secretly acting as an agent for rx a
rival space research organization that
also wants the samples han's team
finally manages to establish contact
with earth using the device and director
choi expresses regret over the death of
three crew members including the spy and
han reminds her that she approved the
co-pilot to be changed at the last
minute he also tells choi about the
survivor and the lack of radiation
levels in the station the lack of
reaction from her makes han suspect that
choi hasn't been completely honest with
him he warns her that if she's been
keeping information from him the success
of this operation will no longer be his
interest choi assures him that she has
no reason to hide anything from him and
that the rescue ships will be sent after
they retrieve the samples as han and
others prepare to look for the intruder
song and her team return back to the
command center song asks han if he knew
that the sample they were sent to
retrieve was water han's guilty silence
answers the question and a flashback
shows him being briefed about the water
that song's sister discovered on the
moon han finally breaks the news that it
was that water which killed everyone at
the ball hey station the lunar water
multiplies endlessly which makes it seem
like an amazing resource if one could
control its multiplication and
commercialize it they have the potential
of saving mankind it's also revealed
that the lunar water springs into action
after coming in contact with a living
organism song feels angry that the
scientists at balham died due to the
lunar water but the government covered
up everything to hide the existence of
lunar water as a way to compensate for
lying to her han agrees to let her
access the data storage of the station
there they come across huge amounts of
data suddenly a green leaf emerging from
the ground catches their attention when
they remove what seems like a lid they
discover the basement covered by green
plants much to their surprise to see
what happens next watch the second part
in series recapped